some of my favorite books
i love the harry potter series
you know guilty pleasure guys i love
twilight
i'm sorry i'm sorry but i love i love
twilight i i love the books uh they're
very you know i just i love the books
they're very romantic books actually
lord of the rings those are actually
great books hobbit and all those books
the magicians apprentice
i really enjoy that that series
and another series that i really enjoy
and i love this guy man and he's such a
weird dude his name is christopher g
nuttle he's got a series called the
school of magic
and it's like a 20 book series man but
it's so in-depth so intense i love it
and i love a book with a good heroine
tell me your favorite books